j'accueille claude perron et albert
dupontel
françois un bon soir claude bonsoir
albert poussoir notion de la rue albert
en vous quittant pianiste virtuose dans
fauteuil d'orchestre de danièle thompson
et on vous retrouve en sdf déjanté dans
votre nouveau film qui s'appelle
enfermés dehors alors le pitch c'est un
sdf qui trouve un uniforme de flic et il
va s'en servir pour aider une femme
interprétée par claude a retrouvé sa
petite fille et se casse sociale devient
en fait sa raison d'exister il décide de
jouer les justiciers voilà vous dit le
pitch m'est venue un soir où je songeais
à manger du monde extérieur
c'est à dire un peu tous les soirs lui
dit ensuite j'ai cherché comment
raconter et l'aspect cartoon sociale m'a
paru de bon aloi
c'est vrai que c'est un cartoon sociale
voilà voilà c'est la meilleure
définition du film conclut ainsi moule
dit moi je pense que c'est ça tout en
gros et sociale en petit ces récompenses
aux police mène de chaplin
mais la réalisation est traitée que
savent rire jones aussi si la bd fil
mais quoi voilà je suis absolument
d'accord moi je suis pas qu'on était sur
écoute
alors c'est un film assez c'est
burlesque qui fait ma règle des choses
désespérées comme tout ce qui est
burlesque quoi désespérer les algériens
on prend le terreau social qui existe et
puis on part de ça je ne comprends pas
d'un constat en traquant pas d'apporter
une révélation aux gens si c'est une
révélation qui a des sdf dans la rue des
banquiers véreux le 20 heures est une
tragédie
par contre l'idée c'était d'avoir un
procès des grands guigne cartoonesque
également pour raconter tout ça monsieur
qui a fait ça très bien il ya cent ans
et s'appelait chaplin c'est une
revisiterait un lait très personnelle
des gourbis de sapinière voilà alors
vous dites ce film est né d'une attitude
inconsciente qui consiste à regarder les
travers du monde avec un nez rouge c'est
vous quoi mais voilà et c'est plus drôle
que bernie quoi sert d'atelier bernie tu
es drôle aussi mais simplement que la ja
va coûter ya un côté plus bénins dans ce
personnage là puisque dès le départ ses
ambitions sont plus triviale il veut
boire manger et être aimé henri arni vu
ça frustre itude voir un nom était déjà
quelque chose de très exagéré points
voilà donc cette nouvelle ère dans le
mur voilà mais c'est là la fin positive
de ce film est aussi honnête que la fin
négative des derniers les tec s'arrêter
une faute de goût de serre ce film mal
se terminer
voilà on va voir à quoi ça ressemble
vais regarder tous les deux la caméra
vous allez dire magnéto sur cèze qu'elle
rouge claude là ok manille dont soit
aussi apparemment magnéto en même temps
1 2 3 benito sèche mais si par exemple
tu es de la police tu fais un coup bas
la police il ya une dame qui te demande
de l'aider dans la rue si cette dame par
exemple elle te dit que on lui a pris
son bébé si jamais cyclique
je mets la nasse usa le parc a fait ça
j'ai reçu des macaques gueule c'est des
gens il faut les décapiter vivant lui
l'appui des à coups de masse et jean
fête du pâté du pape et
j'ai toujours été attiré par les pauvres
ce nouveau film d'albert dupontel
alors j'ai pris ce qu'exige de
développement tels vous êtes dans tous
ses films dans bernie dans le dans le
créateur d'enfermer dehors et vous avez
dit en parlant de claude je préfère les
grandes actrices rare aux mauvaises très
fréquentes
ça j'étais sûr c'était journaux détaille
l'élu vous êtes un petit peu l'homme de
schaffhouse de demander à qui pensez à
kehl aux personnes c'est vrai que je
trouvais avec l'os et 1 5% qui piaffent
et j'aime bien utiliser il faut faire le
mode d'emploi donc voila mon métier des
boutades ça c'est pas sérieux thierry le
film n'est pas sérieux je ne suis pas
sérieux rien n'est sérieux voilà vous
avez beaucoup vous dites son animalité
sa tendresse en même temps qu'elle peut
expliquer mieux que moi ça cet enfant
cet animal animal peut-être dans le sens
où je suis plutôt instinctive que
cérébral en tout cas pour le jeu
d'ailleurs dans la vie aussi geffard
j'ai faim j'ai souvent des swaps et
voilà pourtant au départ il a écrite
pour une actrice espagnole à votre place
quand même elle est morte
ah oui c'est vrai oui j'ai fait un
contrat contre elle ne faut pas déconner
ça c'est pas faire et que l'actrice
espagnole dont l'éclat des morts voilà
donc il a il a ramé pour vous vous
reconquérir
au lieu d'acheter des comptes quand elle
je voulais arrêter attendre longtemps
avant de dire oui j'ai pris mon temps
j'ai fait le tour du périgord d'antan
d'honneur ça s'est passé comme ça tout à
fait donc il ya eu cette actrice
espagnole parce qu'il voulait en fait
enfin il vous dirai mieux que moi ils
voulaient que ce qu'elle soit étrangère
pour accuser encore le fait qu'elle soit
perdue par rapport à l'administration
française et pour récupérer son bébé et
puis et puis donc elle était plus jeune
aussi pour encore le côté plus
vulnérables et donc il est resté encore
en pensée sur sept jeunes de jeunes
personnes dans l'idée est donc petit à
petit sous la menace la torture il a
fini par réaliser qu'en fait il avait en
face de lui quelqu'un de beaucoup mieux
au départ c'est une coproduction franco
espagnole alors au départ même avant ça
c'était un projet américain je vais
tenter l'expérience américaine vous avez
pensé à robin williams et jack nicholson
dépit des appels du pied du cinéma
indépendant américain et en être
vaniteux j répondu voilà après un
sursaut de lucidité de revenir en france
ouais mais j'ai perdu un petit peu
tanger que j'ai croisé des personnes
très intéressante et très très
enthousiaste musique ils sont marrants
comme ça le soir mais le lendemain on
est en face de l'argent et c'est déjà
beaucoup
donc c'est facile d'en manger avec eux
de s'amuser et c'est authentique l'idée
qu'on commence à travailler c'est
compliqué et puis surtout je peux avoir
ou pas je pouvais pas voir le contrôle
de mon travail ça me gênait beaucoup
quoi donc je suis revenu en france
précipitamment et je reconstitue une
petite équipe de vernis vert rue claude
voile a été beaucoup plus sage mais vous
avez passé quand même temps la barre je
fais des allers retours pendant 18 mois
nous allons vous êtes pas acharné à
hollywood non non non non faut pas alors
le film s'est monté en france n'est pas
évident d'arriver à le monter parce que
c'est vrai que le créateur ce n'est pas
été un énorme succès non non mais c'est
ça c'est surtout une question de
le principal investisseur du cinéma en
france et la télévision à la télévision
forcément friands de ce genre de
produits voilà j'ai gagné j'ai aimé
passer en clair c'est si bête que ça
j'ai pas de l'audimat hammett j'ai un
score au box-office mais pas forcément
le climat s'est ou non mais c'est
logique aussi ces mondiaux savoir c'est
une partie du talent c'est de savoir se
vendre
il faudrait qu'on guérit pas avancé
martin le culte est derrière thuram pour
faire des films c'est mon papa je ne me
plains pas donc je connais les règles du
jeu ça va mal vous vous dites je
m'ennuie souvent au cinéma surtout avec
sept postes nouvelle vague qui n'en
finit plus de mourir c'est que souvent
le cinéma à l'étranger français doit
être considérée comme la nouvelle vague
quand il ya des films qui ne ressemble
pas la nouvelle vague ils sont surpris
dit c'est pas du cinéma dans la cuisine
où pierre est parti parce que karol
arrivée on a eu quelques expériences
vont de quelques quelques eu quelques
expériences aux états unis qui était
curieuse ce qui est des gens venaient
est sorti en disant c'est pas des
cinémas français donc on était un peu
embêté on est à astrid culturellement la
nouvelle vague a fait des dégâts malgré
tout pour les petits gars comme moi
c'est tout alors c'est fini le one man
pour toujours et ça fait 15 ans je ne
vais pas au truc quoi non non non je
mange ça me manque pas mais vous avez
fait en fait des courts métrages avant
de faire des sketchs les sketches et
juste une façon de faire connaître
finalement c'est une porte qui s'est
ouverte et j'en resterais toujours les
gens comme sebastian marcher sur la
télévision parce que ces sketches à
s'amuser beaucoup mes copains à l'école
de théâtre j'étais chez vittel mais
c'est vrai que c'était il ya 15 ans a
duré 18 mois je me suis jamais profité
d'une carrière là-dessus avec les sous
du spectacle à titre d'anecdote j'ai
produit mon premier commettra saper le
désiraient quai dans les bonus du dvd du
créateur et puis voilà ça s'appelle
avoir la suite dans les idées et se
succèdent sans encombre est quelque part
non pas du tout sincèrement ça me
frustrait puisque jamais la caméra tout
s'est très bien souvent parler donc
j'aime bien cet outil qu'est la caméra
tout ça très beau très soul ça me
fascine à tort ou à raison j'en sais
rien ça me plaît beaucoup
la scène de frustré parce que je n'étais
que tout - seul sur scène c'était
frustrant comme expression donc voilà
donc c'est juste ça on est pas arrêtée
par rejet arrêté puisqu'il y avait une
femme plus belle qui m'attendait c'est
aussi bête que ça
bien voilà enfermé dehors donc sorti le
5 avril alors le film le pitch comme je
les dis c'est un sdf qui enfile un
costume de flic alors offert une
interview si vous étiez flics